PFT ot Wednesday edition we have solved
the technical issues for Chris Sims
unless I just jinxed it
we we had some fun at the end of the
show Chris you're very you're very
humorous when you're upset I didn't mean
that as an insult
I just way I knew you were gonna be
livid and you were nothing sets you off
like technical difficulties but we're
good to go for now
and we have a chance to talk undeterred
uninterrupted by whatever gremlins may
be lurking in your technological
processes I I don't get it like I sit
here and do this show haven't had one
issue for weeks right and I get a few
text messages on my phone and it's like
my phone took over the connection and
like I couldn't get face time to work on
my iPad and I couldn't get anything to
go through to the studio I mean it did
there was a lot of four-letter words
flying over here at this end household
and it may just be that Phillip got up
early and he's playing call of duty or
fortnight or something like that and say
it could be it could be it might be just
as simple as that
well before he gets into another game
let's get this in we talked yesterday
about the Dalvin cook situation in
Minnesota where as of Monday he
disengaged from the virtual offseason
program I mean the virtual offseason
program is about the end anyway so it's
not like he's gonna miss much and he's
threatened to hold out the Vikings and
cook had been negotiating and I had
somebody that I trust very much tell me
last night that this is not a situation
where the Vikings are going to cave that
they will dig in they're gonna pay what
they have allocated they're not gonna
pay him Christian McCaffrey money and if
push comes to shove that they will
behave like the Chargers did with Melvin
Gordon not like the Cowboys did with
Ezekiel Elliott where if you want to
skip training camp go ahead if you want
to hold out into the regular season go
ahead the Vikings will go forward with
Alexander Madison and the rest of the
guys they have if Dalvin cook decides
he's not going to take what the Vikings
have offered and hold out into the
season they just aren't going to do it
they rarely have this kind of an impasse
with a player and if cook doesn't want
what they're willing to pay the fact
that it's blown up the way that it has
is a sign that that impasse is real and
the Vikings
this person that that I trust who knows
how the team operates strongly believes
they're not going to cave in here and
this potentially is gonna blow up on
cook yeah well you know I could I can
see Minnesota doing that I certainly can
I mean you know the two references you
drew to there as far as Zico Elliott and
Melvin Gordon the situation is different
you know first off hey Melvin Gordon
really good football player but
certainly has some knee issues and I
think that long term you know ability to
play and be successful was a little bit
concerning to the Chargers Zekey ollie
it had great leverage over the Cowboys
the team has been built through the run
game what he can do and they had nobody
on the roster that they could look at to
go oh okay he's not Zeke but we trust
this guy where it's different in
Minnesota one they have salary cap
issues but I think to you and I on our
agreement here like Alexander Madison is
a starting caliber NFL running back he
is he'd be a starter on other teams in
football he's just stuck behind a guy
that's super talented in down and cook
so Mike I ask you like what do you think
that number is that does everybody right
right that's good for Dalvin cook but
not killing the Minnesota Vikings like
what is that number that is fair well 12
12 million yeah for Delia cook the
structure still has a lot to do with it
but you mentioned Madison and here's
some stats from Pro Football Focus that
Pete sent over while we were having this
discussion Dalvin cook last year
averaged four point five yards per carry
Madison 4.6 yards after contact per
carry Dalvin cook 3.1 Alexander Madison
3.2 missed tackles per carry cook 0.17
Madison 0.18 so you know it's not a huge
difference but the point is Madison may
be basically the same guy and I think
back and once we accept the fact that
Gary Kubiak is the offensive court now
the coordinator now of Minnesota Vikings
now the Kevin Stefanski
gone this is the Kubiak Shanahan offense
I think back to what happened in Denver
that period of time where they went from
Terrell Davis he gets injured Elena's
Gary becomes a star he gets injured by
CJ Anderson becomes a star you plug a
guy in it's the system and there are a
lot of guys and I don't take anything
away from doubt and cook because he's a
special talent but the thing is the gap
if the gap isn't all that big between
Cooke and Madison and Madison's
operating under the second season of a
third-round slotted rookie deal yeah and
right hook once 13 14 15 million a year
or more and a certain point you got to
make a business decision and and you
know the fans won't be happy about it
but if Madison comes out of the gates
and and he he has the impact that Cooke
did last year people are gonna forget
about cook pretty quickly that's just
the way it works good deviling you're
right and you know Madison is the type
of talents are gonna you know take the
reins and go with it and be successful
and and you know justify and go in the
Vikings fans everybody go okay this guy
looks awesome - he's a starter okay we
dialed without Dallben cook now I don't
think you know and again I know the
stats are close
I do think Dalvin cook is the better
player there's no doubt about that I
mean he's kind of special and when you
read stats there by PFF and everything
I'm not trying to discredit them but you
know you also got to take into account
when Madison is in the game you know
defenses are going okay they're probably
gonna pass they're not expecting it
Madison of course is pressure which can
lead to him breaking board tackles
because Dalvin cooks more the workhorse
I've been in there on the play-by-play
bases so I'm just trying to give some
context behind those stats but I think
that is very real and I think the best
point you might make Mike is hands down
you're right
you know again this is like a great
system as far as passing the ball this
is a great system and running the ball
and we've seen that you don't have to be
a superstar to kind of look like a
superstar in that Shanahan Kubiak
outside inside zone running scheme and
the scheme is special and they do some
things coaching wise that just the rest
of the league doesn't know exact
what they're doing coaching it so I do
think that from that standpoint cook
loses a little leverage because of all
those little issues we just talked about
it's gonna be a challenge to see how it
all unfolds and ultimately it's in
everyone's interest for this to be done
before the start of training camp so
when cook does show up he's able to have
maximum impact but if he doesn't I look
there's only so much the Vikings are
capable of doing financially and they're
gonna have a value they put on that
position and if cook insists on anything
more than that I just I I I trust and I
believe after I hear the reasoning I had
the conversation with the person last
night I I agree that you know the
Vikings are making their attempt to sign
him and if he wants more than what the
Vikings have budgeted have allocated
have determined is the right number then
next man up it's that simple
yeah we all what's crazy about the
situation is just the current status of
the running back market you know that's
really what it is you know we have some
contracts that have confused the
situation a little bit and you're right
like I look at the Dallben cook and go
like yeah I think somewhere in that 12
million dollar price range is probably
fair to all you know but what skews the
market is guys like David Johnson
Le'Veon Bell who were making north of 13
million and of course haven't looked
that good so I'm sure döblin cook and
his representatives are going wait
they're making that and my players
better than them then why shouldn't he
make north of what they made and of
course you know I think the Vikings are
gonna go while those were stupid
contracts by those teams and they
shouldn't have done that
and I think that would probably be the
appropriate answer you know but a guy
like Derek Henry where a lot of people
view him as one of the top two or three
running back to this board he's only
gonna make ten point two million dollars
this year and Kenyan Drake who got the
eight point four million dollars this
year as well hey Dalvin cook certainly
better than him so I think you're right
somewhere in that 10 to 12 million
dollar a year average type range I think
would be more than fair to doubt and
cook and I would advise Dalvin cook to
do that because I do think this looks
like one of those situations like the
Chargers last year where the Vikings you
know they're gonna dig their heels in it
and go we got a good run
team we got a good running back that we
don't feel like we're gonna fall off
earth without you David Cook well we'll
see how it plays out it's one of the
storylines to definitely watch as the
season approaches we'll be tracking that
and everything else check us out around
the clock at Pro Football Talk comm
we'll be back Thursday with another
edition of PFD live hopefully with no
technical issues either for Kris or for
me we could we can only hope although it
is it is it is entertaining when it
doesn't happen to meet Kris thank you
thank you very much yes I want to
somewhere right now on the way out but I
won't do it okay well done you're
maturing that's good is you close in on
40 you're finally you're finally showing
growingly you're showing you're showing
adulthood you're showing maturity at
least for right now in this moment it
may not last long all right everybody
will see you tomorrow have a great day
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports